Ça tourne au son, ça tourne à l'image
On va faire un petit tour de magie
Regarde, on va faire un petit tour de magie
Nan ça va être de la m***, ça a trop pas marché
J'ai annulé mon tour de magie en live
Je voulais faire changer la chaise mais ça marche pas c'est sûr
Je tente quand même
Est-ce que ça a marché ? Est ce qu'on a vu le cut ou pas ? Je sais pas
Les amis bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo
Bienvenue dans cette 2e édition du show le plus aimé de Youtube
Nan, plus sérieusement j'ai vu tous vos retours sur le 1er "Y'a quoi ?"
J'ai totalement compris ce que vous reprochiez au truc etc
et c'était très bienveillant d'ailleurs vos commentaires
donc merci pour tous ces retours, ça m'a fait plaisir
c'est vrai qu'habituellement quand on a beaucoup de j'aime pas
on se braque, on est pas bien et
et dans les commentaires c'est pas très constructif mais là c'était tout l'inverse
donc merci pour ça c'est important de le souligner
Aujourd'hui un "Y'a quoi" édition spéciale
Une énorme "bombe" qu'il y a eu sur les réseaux sociaux
il y a pas longtemps. Avez-vous entendu parler de ce fameux
nom :  "La ligue du LOL" ? Certainement...
Alors petit disclaimer je suis pas du tout journaliste si vous voulez voir
des articles complets, un vrai travail de journalistes
bah allez en description j'aurai mis
pas mal de liens qui peuvent vous être utiles. Je fais cette vidéo juste pour ouvrir le dialogue sur ce qui s'est passé
Et du coup sensibiliser ceux qui me suivent vis-à-vis du harcèlement qui est
quelque chose de terrible
Mais commençons par le commencement : début février on voit apparaître sur twitter plusieurs témoignages
qui parlent de harcèlement
Des victimes sortent du silence, ça fait un peu de bruit mais pas tant que ça
Quelques jours après il y a un article du site de questions-réponses "Checknews", un site qui appartient à Libération
qui révèle de nombreuses accusations et preuves de harcèlement
perpétrées par un certain groupe
dont le nom serait "La ligue du LOL"
S'en suit alors un clash sur twitter avec d'un côté
Alexandre Hervaud, le boss du service web
de Libération. Et de l'autre côté IrisKv
et dariamarx
Pourquoi il y a clash, parce que ces dernières trouvent que l'article est trop succint
que c'est trop vide par rapport au sujet traité
et qu'il y a beaucoup plus  de choses que ça à dire
Florence Porcel et Capucine Piot décident le lendemain
de prendre la parole pour témoigner, pareil, du harcèlement
qu'elles ont subi.
A partir de là effet boule de neige mais dans le bon sens
les victimes de ce groupe se rendent compte qu'elles sont pas seules
que beaucoup d'autres gens ont subi ça
et elles voient ces autres gens en train de sortir
du silence et du coup elles vont elles-même sortir du silence
et témoigner
Donc on comprend qu'il y a un seul et même groupe
qui a harcelé toutes ces personnes, voilà
J'espère que tout est clair pour vous à partir de là
C'est la petite intro pour vous faire comprendre comment tout ça
a été amené sur le tapis, vous savez où on va
Mais qu'est-ce que la ligue du LOL Lucas, c'est quoi
C'est des mecs juste qui font des tweets un peu drôles et les gens RT ?
Pas du tout c'est des gros fils de p*
Désolé mais quand t'as lu tous les témoignages
t'as un seum en toi qui est f ou
La ligue du LOL c'est un groupe constitué essentiellement d'hommes
qui passait son temps à, comme ils disent
"Rire, troller", mais pas du tout
ils passaient juste leur temps à harceler d'autres gens
qui étaient essentiellement des femmes, donc on avait le droit
à des insultes sexistes, des insultes homophobes,
des insultes racistes, bref vous prenez tout ce qui se fait
de pire, et qui peut sortir de la bouche d'un humain
Bah ça sortait de la bouche de la ligue du LOL. Nickel !
Les membres du groupe c'était essentiellement un cercles de journalistes
et de communicants qui bossaient dans des rédactions ou dans des
agences de pub influentes à Paris
Alors il faut savoir que c'était des gens majeurs, c'était pas un groupe d'enfants
de quinze ans qui savait pas ce qu'il faisait
C'était des gens qui avaient la vingtaine au moins
la vingtaine, il y en a même certains qui avaient la trentaine
Donc à cet âge-là on est parfaitement responsables
Ok, faut arrêter ces conneries de "j'étais jeune"
Non non non non !
Et là une question me taraude les amis, aidez-moi, éclairez ma lanterne
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire dans la vie quand on est un homme
blanc, et en plus on a un travail
Et si on allait exploser ceux qui galèrent
et qui débutent ? Yess
Les membres de la ligue du LOL parlaient donc entre eux  sur un groupe
Facebook privé qui s'appelait "La ligue du LOL"
et sur lequel ils postaient des photomontages dégradants
des infos persos, des trucs horribles
sur les gens et sur leurs potentielles cibles.
Ça sortait sur un groupe privé sauf que derrière, bien entendu,
ça sortait en public, ils mettaient ça sur les réseaux sociaux
ils mettaient au point des stratagèmes pour vraiment
affecter le plus la vie de la personne, lui faire le plus de mal possible,
la traîner vraiment dans la boue publiquement.
Et c’est là que ça devient un gros bordel
qui fait du mal à beaucoup de gens, et c’est ignoble.
Il est aussi important de noter que la ligue du LOL
c’est pas un groupe qui contient un nombre de membres précis etc…
ok il y a des gens qui ont créé ce groupe privé
qui s’appelait la ligue du LOL mais y a aussi pleiiin
d’autres gens qui sont tout aussi coupables
et qui étaient pas dans le groupe mais qui ont suivi
les agissements des gens du groupe.
Et ces gens là essaient de se dédouaner en disant
«non non moi j’étais pas dans la ligue du LOL» Mais mec !
Tu faisais exactement la même chose ! C’est pas parce qu’il y a pas marqué
ligue du Lol au début de ton pseudo que tu vaux mieux qu’eux en fait !
Alors Luca c’est bien beau tu nous parles de la ligue du LOL
des gens qui sont méchants qui ont harcelé mais ils ont fait quoi en fait ?
On veut du concret, mais ça arrive !
Laisser moi construire ma vidéo avec plusieurs points clés
Alors je vous l'ai dit ils s'attaquaient essentiellement aux  femmes
Magnifique !
Donc les mecs choisissaient une cible c'était un petit jeu pour eux
et ils se mettaient ensuite à l'attaquer
Ils étaient plusieurs dessus en plus c'était des gros lâches
Et ils l'attaquaient à base de publications, de photomontages dégradants,
d'insultes, tout ce qu'ils pouvaient mettre en place
et qui allait décourager la personne face à qui ils étaient
et lui faire du mal.
Je sais c'est chelou comme but dans la vie de faire ça
mais c’était leur but à eux apparemment...
Pour vous dire à quel point c'est des oufs
les mecs allaient même jusqu'à demander des informations personnelles
sur la cible qu'ils avaient choisis auprès de ses collègues les plus proches
Y a un problème dans le cerveau, clairement...
Bref, on va parler de concret en se basant sur un témoignage
en se basant sur le témoignage de @LeReilly
Pourquoi je parle de son témoignage à lui et pas de l'un de tout les autres que j'ai vu?
Parce que son témoignage à lui que j'ai lu en premier
et qui m'a donc mit la puce à l'oreille
Alors disclaimer, il s'agit ici d'un homme blanc, hétéro
qui du coup ne représente pas du tout la majorité des victimes
de la ligue du LOL qui était, comme je vous l'ai dit,
essentiellement des femmes...
Je vais donc reprendre points par points ce qu'il lui est arrivé
en reprenant ses propos, je vais pas déformer
ce qu'il lui ai arrivé ou quoi que ce soit
je vais vraiment vous expliquer lui ce qu'il a vécu
Vous pouvez retrouver une énorme partie des autres témoignages en description
Comme je vous ai dit je mettrai tous les liens qu'il faut
C'est donc quelqu'un qui, à l 'époque
C'était il y a plusieurs années ce dont je vous parle,
tenais un blog sur lequel il partageait ces états d'âme
voilà il écrivait des textes c'est cool
Quelqu'un comme vous et moi quand il tombe sur ça
soit ça va l'intéresser
il va lire, il va kiffer
soit ça l'intéresse pas et il passe à autre chose et il l'ignore
mais quelqu'un de la ligue du LOL
il va juste dire
" Ah mais c'est un fragile lui, venez on va se moquer un peu sur les réseaux Ah Ah Ah "
" Le nul, le gros nul, il écrit des textes
et il y met des sentiments dedans le gros nul "
J'exagère même pas c'est vraiment ça qu'ils se disent
Donc déjà dans cette démarche, il y a un vrai problème
Bref. Son harcèlement, ça a donc commencer par recevoir des insultes
sur Twitter venant de comptes Twitter appartenant à la ligue du LOL
sauf qu'il y a un effet boule de neige
Comme les mecs à la ligue de LOL à l'époque faut se dire c'était les king de twitter
qu'ils avaient des énormes communauté..euh sur Twitter et bah il y a des gens qui suivaient ce qui faisaient.
En pensant que c'était bonne enfant, en pensant que c'était "cool" de faire ça.. que c'était "stylé"
Et du coup ces gens là qui étaient hors de la ligue du LOL ce sont mis à les suivre et à insulter
du coup Le Reilly et à se moquer de la même manière que les gens de la ligue du LOL
Le Reilly dit quelque chose de hyper intéressant
qui fait bien comprendre ce que c'est que le harcèlement
dans son témoignage il dit que c'est l'accumulation de chaque petit acte individuel
qui finit par faire très très très très mal
Et c'est vrai c'est important de le souligner parce que les personnes
qui ont harcelé quand ils présentent leurs excuses ils disent
"Mais ça va j'ai juste fait ça, ça va c'est rien"
Et ils ont pas conscience que en fait il y a des dizaines ou centaines d'autres personnes
qui ont fait la même chose qu'eux, et que l'accumulation de tout ça c'est ce qui fait ultra mal
Et je peux vous dire que les harceleurs là, ils en avaient pas conscience !!
Parallèlement à ça, il y a même un mec qui est allé jusqu'à créer un compte
qui s'appelait LeReilly, qui portait le nom du coup de Le Reilly
donc qui a usurpé totalement son identité
Et à aller sur des blogs de copines féministes à Le Reilly
pour les insulter, faire des insultes sexistes, misogynes tout ça
bon vous connaissez, tout ce qu'il y a de pire quoi !
sauf que du coup les copines de Le Reilly
pensant que c'était vraiment Le Reilly qui avait commenté ça
l'ont appelé, y a eu des engueulades, des embrouilles etc
bref, usurper l'identité de quelqu'un pour provoquer des réactions
au sein de sa vie privée c'est pitoyable
et c'est ce genre de trucs que les mecs font quand même, c'est dingue !
Les mecs ne se sont pas arrêté là, ils ont ensuite trouvé une autre technique
pour faire chier le Reilly
en fait ce qu'ils attendent c'est une réaction de la part du gars
Ils veulent vraiment le traîner dans la boue jusqu'à ce qu'il craque
pour ensuite se foutre de sa gueule quand il craque
Ils ont commencé à lire les textes les plus sentimentaux de Le Reilly
Et à mettre ça sur un fond de violon triste, pour se foutre de sa gueule
Ils publiaient ça sur SoundCloud, ils invitaient plein de gens à le faire
Et sur plusieurs semaines il y a eu plus de 20 musiques qui ont été mises en ligne
comme ça sur SoundCould, et la pochette de l'album c'était
des photos personnelles de Le Reilly qui étaient détournées
Toujours dans le but de dégrader son image, toujours plus
Plus tard, Le Reilly a eu une altercation avec l'un de ses harceleurs
dans un bar, ils en sont presque venus aux mains
Et après ça Le Reilly a décidé de dévoiler l'identité de l'un de ses harceleurs publiquement
Donc son nom, prénom, et son adresse
Là, quand on apprend ça on se dit Putain y a une justice !
Il lui a mis dans la gueule un petit pourcentage de ce que lui il s'est mangé dans la gueule
C'est beau !
A votre avis, comment a réagi le harceleur ? Comme un bonhomme !
En mode "mais mec ça m'atteint pas, je m'en bats les couilles ! "
PASDUTOUT!!!
Cette personne s'est juste offusquée sur les réseaux sociaux
Elle a trouvé ça pitoyable de la part de Le Reilly
Et ça montre vraiment à quel point cette personne n'avait pas conscience
de ce qu'elle infligeait à Le Reilly, de ce qu'elle faisait
Cette personne n'avait aucun recul sur ce qu'elle faisait
C'est fou d'être à ce point déconnecté de la réalité, de la conséquence de nos actes
Cette personne s'est tout simplement vengée derrière en faisant un truc pitoyable
Il a fait un photomontage pornographique avec la tête de Le Reilly
et il envoyait ce montage photo à plein de mineurs
et il leur posait comme question : "Salut, je m'appelle @LeReilly
j'adore faire telle position sexuelle, est-ce que ça t'intéresse ?"
Donc il y a une nouvelle fois usurpation d'identité, qui est le plus gros truc
de lâche et de c****** que tu peux faire
Parce que les conséquences de ça sont dévastatrices
Et donc Le Reilly recevait dans ses notifications des gens qui répondaient en fait
au faux Le Reilly, qui leur envoyait ce photomontage et leur demandait des trucs sexuels
Et du coup ça a commencé à tourner un peu,
et plein de gens ont ensuite vu Le Reilly ensuite comme un pédophile, voilà.
Alors qu'il n'a rien commis de tout ça !
Et ce qui est horrible c'est que du coup quand il ouvrait Twitter dans ses notifs il y avait que ça
Comme le gars l'avait mentionné dans sa question, dans les notifications de Le Reilly
y avait que ça en fait, que les réponses des mineurs face à ça
Du coup je pense que quand il t'arrive ça t'as plus trop envie d'ouvrir Twitter
et du coup tu t'isoles, et c'est tout ce qu'ils veulent
ces gros chiens, ils veulent vraiment isoler leurs victimes
car elles sont encore plus fragiles et plus facilement attaquables
Bref, tout ce qu'on peut faire de plus lâche
c'est ce que font les harceleurs.
Voilà, dites vous juste ça
Alors là, certains d’entre vous peuvent se dire
"Mais put**n mais pourquoi les mecs faisaient ça
et restaient dans l'impunité la plus totale?"
Je veux dire "pourquoi personne n’aillaient les balancer,
pourquoi les victimes ne parlaient pas, pourquoi...enfin..."
C'est très complexe quand on est dans la situation des harcelés
et je pense qu'on peut même pas imaginer être à leur place
tant qu'on l'a pas vécu
Vu qu'ils avaient une communauté énorme
t'avais pas trop intérêt à te fâcher, à t'embrouiller avec eux
parce que sinon y avait toute leur communauté qui les suivait
ils avaient des contacts, etc...
Et bref, ça pouvait te faire du tort d'une manière ou d'une autre...
Et en plus il y avait un double effet pervers
C'est-à-dire que les gens avaient envie de suivre ces gars là
et de faire comme eux pour gagner un peu de leurs fame et de leurs abonnés
Et ouais c'est triste, vraiment comme au collège
On va suivre, des fois, des comportements nuls parce que
ces comportements nuls là sont vus comme des trucs cool
et on veut faire parti des mecs cools
et là c'est vraiment le même délire
Bon du coup Luca là ! Vu que les victimes ont
eu le courage de sortir du silence il se passe quoi là ?
Est-ce qu'ils vont payer le prix de leurs actes ou pas ?
Alors légalement, il faut que y ait des poursuites judiciaires
qui soient entamées, c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
que des victimes aillent en Justice, les attaquent en Justice
pour qu'ils aient une sanction pénale
Je suis personne pour me mettre à leur place,
mais je pense que si j'avais vécu un enfer comme ça pendant des années
j'aurais envie de tout sauf de raviver ces souvenirs horribles
et de revoir la gueule des mecs qui m'ont fait tant de mal
donc du coup c'est très compliqué
En revanche le tribunal populaire lui
les a REKT comme on dit
Suite à la montée en force des témoignages
et à la médiatisation des noms de certains,
et bien ils ont tout simplement été licenciés
dégagés des rédactions
ou des agences de pub dans lesquelles ils travaillaient.
Mais comment ont-ils réagi face à la montée des témoignages ?
Ils ont sûrement pris conscience du mal qu'ils ont fait
et de leur comportement dangereux et puéril !
Et ils ont donc fini par faire des excuses sincères
comme tout adulte responsable.
PAS!
PAS!DU!
PAS!DU!TOUUUUT!
Bah figurez vous que la plupart d'entre eux
quand les témoignages ont commencé à sortir
et que tout ça a pris un peu de l'ampleur
ils se sont empressés d'aller supprimer pleiiin de leurs tweets
comme des gros lâches !
Y a même un mec qui clashait et harcelait vla les gens
sur Twitter qui a supprimé
78000 tweets en 2 jours
Imaginez la taille de la goutte de sueur
qui coulait sur la tempe de ce gars
quand il a vu les gens commencer à témoigner
Alors attention ils ont pas tous réagi comme ça
mais honnêtement, quand tu lis les excuses
tu comprends que ils ont pas du tout pris conscience, au moment de leurs excuses,
de la gravité de ce qu'ils ont fait, en fait
et c'est ça qui est triste
Si cette vidéo là peut aider des gens à comprendre
à quel point c'est grave de faire ça,
j'ai réussi ma mission fictive que je me suis donné
et je suis content
Ca aura servi à quelque chose de faire cette vidéo en fait
BREEEF
Concluons tout ce merdier
Déjà, s'il vous plait, faites gaffe après avoir vu cette vidéo,
je sais que vous avez la haine contre les gars qui ont harcelé d'autres gens
qui ont fait tant de mal
Mais ne soyons pas stupides
Ne reproduisons pas ce que ces gars ont fait
N'allons pas harceler les harceleurs c'est débile de faire ça.
C'est vraiment dans un but informatif que j'ai fait cette vidéo
Pour que les gens comprennent ce que c'est que le harcèlement
et qu'ils ne reproduisent surtout pas
consciemment ou inconsciemment
ces agissements horribles
Deuxièmement, je rappelle que le harcèlement
c'est un truc que y a essentiellement dans les cours de récréation
au collège ou au lycée
Y a d'ailleurs une journée annuelle contre le harcèlement
Pourquoi c'est essentiellement au collège et au lycée ?
Parce que c'est une phase où on se construit
où le moyen le plus simple de se mettre en avant
bah c'est en rabaissant un autre
Mais où on est à un âge où on se rend pas compte
de ce qu'on lui fait à cette personne, du mal qu'on fait
on se rend pas compte qu'on harcèle.
Si vous êtes jeune et que vous regardez cette vidéo,
sachez que ce n'est pas du tout drôle ou cool de racketter
de frapper quelqu'un,
de l'insulter ou de se moquer de lui tous les jours,
que ce soit dans la vie ou virtuellement
le cyberharcèlement c'est au même plan que le harcèlement
ça fait autant de mal c'est la même chose,
c'est pas parce qu'il y a un écran que c'est différent
c'est exactement pareil !
Faire ça c'est pas du tout stylé, c'est pas du tout cool
et ça vous rendra pas du tout meilleurs ou respectables
Pas du tout !
Troisièmement, pourquoi parler de la ligue du LOL ?
Parce que c'est une bonne occasion pour remettre les pendules à l'heure
sur ce qu'est le harcèlement, et ses conséquences.
Et surtout j'étais vraiment scotché
en découvrant ça, moi j'ai pas du tout vécu de harcèlement
même étant adulte, ni pas ces mecs, ni par d'autres
Mais j'étais scotché de voir que
on peut être un adulte, on peut avoir la vingtaine
la trentaine, avoir un taf,
et faire ça comme une grosse m***e quoi
C'est fou !
Peu importe notre âge, on peut pas encaisser
d'être traîné comme ça publiquement dans la boue
d'être isolé, d'être moqué
de voir son identité usurpée par un autre
et qui est mal intentionné
On peut pas
Que t'aies 13 ans ou 30 ans ces agissements là ils seront jamais marrants
Ca sera jamais drôle, ça fera toujours mal
Et bravo, bravo
parce que vous avez réussi à sortir du silence
alors que ça doit être une chose terrifiante et très difficile
Et vous les avez ken quoi !
Et c'est ce qu'ils méritaient pour avoir fait ça
et maintenant c'est la vraie justice j'espère qui va s'en occuper
Et j'espère que ça donnera beaucoup moins envie aux gens
d'avoir ces comportements là.
Je le rappelle, si vous regardez cette vidéo et que vous êtes victime de harcèlement
ou de cyberharcèlement
ne vous isolez pas, surtout
Il faut en parler à vos amis, à votre famille, à vos proches
Il y a même un numéro qui a été mis en place par l'Etat
Que vous pouvez appeler
si vous souffrez tous les jours de harcèlement, ils vous aideront
Et aussi, si vous êtes pas forcément victime de harcèlement
mais que vous souhaitez aider concrètement
les gens qui ont vécu cet enfer
il existe une cagnotte, qui a été lancée par la fondation des femmes
et c'est une cagnotte qui vise à soutenir les frais de Justice
des femmes victimes de cyberharcèlement
Je le rappelle, les femmes sont les premières à être victimes de harcèlement
que ce soit en ligne ou dans la cours de récréation
Donc voilà, si vous voulez exprimer votre soutien direct
envers ces personnes, n'hésitez pas !
Qui suis-je pour parler de tout ça alors que je suis un mec, j'en sais rien
mais si je peux utiliser ma notoriété pour tenter
d'aider et d'améliorer la situation d'autres gens
qui vivent un truc injuste et horrible
Et bah tant mieux, je suis ravi !
Voilà ! Je pense que j'ai tout dit !
J'espère m'être bien exprimé
eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeet voilà
Je vous fais plein de bisous (nous aussi <3)
c'était un peu badant ce sujet mais c'était très important d'en parler
la ligue du LOL c'était vraiment la bonne occasion pour en parler, et voilà !
Merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo !
Badez pas ! Au contraire c'est très positif ce qui se passe !
L'effet boule de neige là il est positif
grâce à ces gens qui sont sortis du silence
Merci à eux encore une fois et courage !
Puis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo plus positive !
Je vous fais des bisous, à bientôt, au revoir !!